we're brainwashing men and trying to
turn them into women I feel like women
it's so sad to say well you like the guy
that actually does nothing call me
delusional call me naive but I just hate
the whole the whole hookup culture don't
ask for equality if I'm gonna pay for
everything high quality good things are
not are not frequent men truly care
about beauty and keeping yourself
together you don't want to be in a
situation with somebody where it's going
to be competitive do you know that
Justin do you know the candy store
analogy can you tell us yeah I've heard
Tate say it before
um so basically the way I've heard him
explain it I've never used it but
a man starts his life off at the bottom
of a mountain and he fights his ass off
and he gets hit by rocks and he gets
torn up in his ass handed to him and he
gets beat up and he falls down the
mountain has to start over goes bankrupt
he finally fights and fights and fights
and Claws away and he gets to the top of
the mountain and he gets into the candy
shop and he eats his first piece of
candy
and they tell them that's the only piece
he can have
and generally a man that's done all of
that work is going to be like you
I'm gonna take over the whole store
because very very very few men will ever
get up that mountain it's called the one
percent for a reason and it is a dog
fight
and that's what he's referring to it's
the thing that drives him in now there's
a lot of men out there that'll say oh
that's no using it as a dating strategy
any man
that could
love his wife tuck his kids in at night
be a good man provide for his entire
family be there as a father be a
provider be the hero for his family and
sleep with a couple women every now and
then would do it and anybody that says
otherwise a flyer
straight up and and look I know that
sucks and it's not fair and it's
completely not fair but it is the
reality of the world and I think
sometimes when we talk about these
subjects we get lost between the
realities of the world and the Motions
because I know it I know it hurts it
does but it is absolutely true
wow
[Laughter]
what do you guys think of that
silence every test that an extent oh no
not to a certain extent speaking to the
mic
their silence agrees with me they don't
have silence agrees that's what I was
going to do yeah their silence agrees
with me and look man I'm sorry
yeah and I get it and and like I said
before if I could pay a million dollars
to cut it off
I actually would I would absolutely cut
it off I think it's a waste of time
it will haunt a man it is in us just in
US
oh yeah it is it's an assault it's in
every one of us it's just it's just the
fact that a lot of men don't want to
climb that mountain yeah and so they'll
trade off things that they don't
actually want to do to get some piece of
candy
but the men that really want to hustle
want the whole store and
generally that's the man that you're
going to admire and look up to because
he has ambition he has Drive in his life
he's a hard worker you believe in him
and most of all you trust him to take
care of you yeah that's all I'm saying
and I don't mean to be disrespectful but
I genuinely want you to hear me
because I fear that if young women that
are young and beautiful like you girls
are are taking advice
from older women that are not happy you
are going to find yourself in that same
position
I'm saying it look as as heated as it
got I'm saying this out of love not not
to put you down I genuinely believe it
and I'm also not manipulating you
because I'm not trying to get with any
of you I'm going to get on a plane in a
couple days you know what I'm saying but
please let me leave this with you or
watch it again
any man that could would
I often say I'm not doing anything that
any other man would not do if he could
all right I love you all
I'm curious did any of you change your
opinion on cheating after listening to
him or after having this conversation
tonight I hate that it's called cheating
in the first place I hate that school
she is because because the cheating is a
triggering part you know like if he sets
you down
like like pretty teeth said
you know she's like I wouldn't like it
but I would appreciate the truth yeah
it's the deceit that really is gonna
upset you because he's killing himself
for you he loves you more than anything
you take a bullet for you and the slags
on the side dude he don't even want him
in his bed at night
he's in love with you
yeah because it's you know how you guys
get emotional for no reason men are like
yeah so are you saying it's just like an
ego stroke
no that's the point it's not about ego
at all it's not about ego at all like
men that sleep with women just to feel
better about themselves are super
insecure yeah you're lacking something
right they're lacking something no no it
is more like it's more like this primal
thing inside of you that will not get
out of your head so is it Primal
or is it lacking something no no
surprise Primal it's completely Primal
does does the fact that 8 000 years ago
17 women reproduced for every one man
does that mean anything to you does that
show at all that it's primal
that always in history there's always
been more women reproducing for men I
think historically yeah but like so if
something we try and adapt like where
humans were you know creatures of
adaptation like I would try my best to
adapt if I didn't if something didn't
sit sit right with me but okay so so if
in modern society we're going back to
that like we're trending more towards
sharing men
no to be fair I don't even like to share
my food so best move I'm not sure
you're wrong you're wrong you have again
because we spoke about you've been in
situationship so you were sharing a guy
you're sharing guys right now but we're
beating a dead horse right you're all
sharing guys right now I'm not sharing
another one well we keep coming back to
the same we keep coming back to the same
point because you guys whenever whenever
Justin whenever Justin makes it or
somebody makes the point and says well
no Matt this is how men are white this
is how they're programmed these are the
things that they want then somebody on
the couch or wherever says um oh but not
all of them like like you did and it's
kind of like but no but we keep we keep
beating the same horse they they do all
want to do it they or they they are all
programmed not all of them necessarily
will act on it but that's partly down to
okay there's gonna be a few unicorns who
aren't going to act on it because
they're super amazing whatever guys I
think so repercussions are scared yeah
yeah probably yes but for the most part
for the most part they're not going to
act on it because then they don't have
the ability to because they're not high
enough and in the food chain okay the
guys are at the top they are going to
act on it and that's just how it is it's
also character as well right yeah I know
you think sorry go on it's also a
character like I think I can personally
relate because at some point you have a
connection that's distinct enough with
someone that it takes a long time for
that urge to come back yeah she'll come
back though sure yeah about about 18
months probably yeah I'm not I'm not
gonna lie even for me I'll be like you
know what I could like really Vibe with
someone like she's one in a million
she's got chat we're cool but I part of
me knows that in like in like a year
maybe two some people been together for
20 years I know eventually
two becomes one why don't you think like
that well I I know I'll mark that that's
one of the reasons I didn't have
relationship when I was younger because
I thought I don't want to do that I
don't mess someone up but I realize bro
I'm always it's just human nature it's
novelty yeah I've tried to fix myself in
my 20s I thought something was wrong
with me and I thought I was all
up and I hated myself for a long time
yeah I broke up with Miss Louisiana in
college because I like I felt like I
couldn't do it and I didn't want to be a
piece of and I wouldn't try to pray
about it and do all this church stuff
and I couldn't defined it was just a
pattern that would not leave me in and I
was I was leaving women that I loved was
that because there's something to if
like yourself no not at all it was
literally what I'm telling you I
wouldn't lie to you and let me let me
nail it home with this
it could be an ugly woman
it's an ugly woman I could eat for me
it's hungry and horny to a man it's
pretty much the same thing I gotta
stress this to you no do you know what I
do agree with that like I do agree that
it's nothing to do with the looks it
doesn't matter is she I don't bro does
it breathe like men are disgusting that
is the first thing that I actually 100
like agree with you on she could be the
ugliest girl in the world but he said
well it's like the old thing it's like
it's like the old thing you know you've
got steak at home but sometimes you just
fancy going out for a McDonald's you
know what I mean and that's just the
reality yeah
it's not even about cheap it's just
about different and it's like this thing
is people people demonize it and act
like you know is this more bro it is
wired into US it almost comes out of us
in a way and and again I cannot stress
this enough if I could pay to get rid of
that feeling I would absolutely do it
100 I guess it's nice it's not nice
that's the wrong word but I guess it's
like
a bit more
that he's sat there saying that if he
could get rid of it he would do you know
what I mean yeah because it's
counterproductive yeah
know what I mean it's like if you're
saying that you could I'd get rid of
this if I I would pay to get rid of it
yes see that's reassurance for us girls
but you don't probably think that you're
reassuring is saying that that's just
something that you personally believe
what John was saying for us girls that
is reassurance
wants to do that I don't know I think
modern women don't really hear these
things though I think it's hard for us
there's not many men that can say it and
get away with it there's no spaces to be
honest yeah I think Pearly things is a
safe space in some ways right
but it's not but it's not but let me
tell you something else about you guys I
have a platform right women see my
content women women that I see will see
me say this and they'll see me anyway
you understand what I'm saying like yeah
I'm not of course I'm not trying to
bully y'all like I have this completely
many many many men cannot say what I'm
saying and get away oh yeah and so
I know you're not used to hearing it and
and for that reason I'm trying to be
graceful right now because I feel like
earlier it got heated but truly if I
could get rid of it yeah if I could get
rid of it I truly mean it up here
for the ladies um what questions do you
guys have for men that you don't
understand about men
[Music]
I think I think my like confusion is
what does the the mind that you know
that fights through all these battles
and gets to the candy store and tries to
take it what does that look like in
today's world that's what's I think
that's a problem with um with us young
younger women I don't know it's not it's
not like back in the day where it was
clear we live in a different world you
know the social media it confuses us you
know so we're just like what we the
words like rappers and footballers and
um you know Drake get thrown into these
conversations and it's like oh yeah
that's what a high value man is but it's
like an accurate question it's like what
is what does that guy look like in
today's society or is it or is it the
same well she read it off but I don't
think you have to be Drake to be high
value as I said I don't like I don't
like the word
you know I don't like the alpha the beta
the high value I don't like any of those
things but I think a man that completely
takes care of business and can give you
a life that you would have never had
otherwise and he can be the hero to you
and he takes pride in that not in um not
by belittling you but by loving you and
empowering you to level up to where he's
trying to go so you can be on his arm
when he's at that event yeah that's the
right way you know what I'm saying
it's not about belittling yeah it's
about building up and that's why I asked
you the question I asked you earlier
yes ma'am I know yeah and but when you
have a real man in front of you yeah he
wants to build you up that's how you
can't even say that people are high
value men until you actually like that
like Drake to be honest you've never
really I've never really seen him with
like a proper light in a proper like
relationship right and that's a place
and that's a placeholder situation now
we'll say that it's probably smart to
protect the queen
in that regard yeah if Drake is smart
he'll never let you see her yeah yeah
that makes sense of course but
hopefully if that woman exists he's
building her up he's almost doing
everything he can to put every amount of
knowledge in her so she's qualified to
be with him at the Grammys and he
understood yes listen baby you gotta you
gotta dress like you can talk like this
when they do this do this start with the
forks here like he loves her I pick you
so I develop you and I protect you from
the world like I'm here to protect you
if it's me and you and I've got you and
the thing I think why it's so hard for
like women to like understand that is
because that now is seen as so toxic and
it's like anyone that acts like that
it's all your toxic man or it's coming
from insecurities we are living an
upside down world and even if we do go
back to the Bible yeah like kings they
did have um
and not just multiple wise but they also
had um what's it called concubines
and it kind of makes sense that these
people were so loved by God and it's
like adultery it kind of makes sense for
you to say cheating is when you're
what is toxic masculinity anyway it's
just a couple of words it's just a
buzzword that somebody's made up and it
now gets applied to all manner of things
that just because somebody doesn't like
it it's the easy way to attack a weak
man and get him to shut up yeah I've had
a lot of a lot of feminists say that
they've they subconsciously associate
masculinity with negativity that's where
it comes from that they they
subconsciously don't like men
and they act they acted out they don't
know who they are it's true it's like
even when they say um he needs to open
up more and be more emotionally
available you're teaching a man to be a
woman men don't men don't um talk about
their problems the same way that women
do they want to bring them down and
they're and they're automatically
assuming that the like the female wit
like the female way is the right way and
so yeah and so like they're saying the
the male way of dealing with problems
like getting being like aggressive
getting into a fight
um not talking about them that's wrong
but the female way of talking about our
problems is right yeah and it's like
we're brainwashing men and trying to
turn them into women
they will tell you that as well and
they're learning that in school as well
I went out with someone I think I I
mentioned that I was reassessing the way
I approached some relationships in an
effort to provide more value to people
who cared about me because I can be too
introverted sometimes and her immediate
response was oh someone's growing up
this is a grown woman and I she wants to
apologize for it proficially after but I
I noticed these things I was like that's
what you really think right you think oh
I get therapy if you really listen to
them how they think when they say I want
to be his mother I have to act like his
mother it's it's there guys if you
listen long enough it's there but to
answer your question as to what uh
respectful man is I would say
I I am somewhat respectable so I want to
give my opinion in dance I noticed that
a lot of the women go for the teachers
who are very overtly sexual and who know
how to press their buttons they know
exactly how to say things how to create
the drama that women like and only after
they've been with that guy do they then
realize oh I want to have like a more
someone who's actually going to commit
to me as well as being a sexy dance
teacher so they get with some loser who
does a lot of work who talks to everyone
who's not particularly attractive and
then that doesn't work out then they
come to me and be like okay you've got
all these qualities but now you've
already disqualified yourself yeah you
know because I spoke to you a while ago
I normally do this I talk to women I ask
them out I'm not I'm not the best I
don't say like particularly witty things
or interesting things I do that on
purpose because I don't think I have to
be witty to spend time with someone to
get to know someone I think the effort
in itself is valuable so I let them
filter me out knowing that yeah you're
gonna get with Pedro and Juan and then
it's gonna be Tim and David and then
you're gonna be back here winking at me
every Saturday and you know and it's a
shame they have to learn through
experience but it's literally a cycle
dance also learn to dance you will you
will see the line you learn so quickly
so value those qualities value the guy
who comes in he's playing by example
buddy the man who have values value the
men who aren't chasing I know it's it's
easy to pick the guy who's constantly
chasing you he's texting every day he's
he's doing the most but that doesn't
necessarily mean it's valuable that
doesn't necessarily mean he likes you
you could just be horny but I feel like
a high value man a woman will want a
woman want him without him doing
anything yes I agree like I feel like I
feel like you like women like yeah like
I feel like women it's so sad to say but
you like the guy that actually does not
like my brother he's someone he told me
that he's very good looking my brother
yeah he used to do modeling and stuff
and he told me he's never spoken that
he's never like gone to speak to a girl
before like a girl has always just come
to him and I was like what like are you
serious and he was like yeah but it's
like I don't know if he's gonna find his
wife that way but I don't think he's
looking for wife right now but it's like
the woman will always come to you if
you're just you just Attract it well I
think generally in human nature we want
the things that we can't quite get you
know yeah you can't quite grab hold off
but it seems to be particularly cute in
women as far as dating is concerned you
know they won that guy they think they
can't quite get him they can't quite get
hold of him you know maybe he's too and
it's the hypergamy thing isn't it you
know it's it's it's easy a little bit
too high value for me is he slightly out
of my reach those are the guys that they
tend to want or they or you tend to want
on a visceral sort of level he loves me
loves me not hmm
what what do you want to know about men
me yeah what questions do you have
uh I might have to have a little think
you know yeah I'll pass it on to double
it and pass it on to the next person
um I don't really have anything I want
to learn about men particularly
to be honest I don't have like any
actual questions you were brought up in
Brazil were you you were born in Brazil
yeah so I was born in America then I
moved to Brazil right okay because
obviously the society there is a lot
more traditional than here right so you
see a lot of differences with the when
you're here like my family is like an
extremely traditional family like my
parents expect me to get married in the
next few years yeah your wife my mom's
like growing up my mum would make like
jokes like oh like see it I would eat
something and leave the wrap on the
table should be like oh your husband's
gonna send you back if you continue this
Behavior just like little things like
that you know I have a question and
don't don't take offense to this how
does your mom like the tattoos and the
nose rings and the crop tops because you
see like you say you're raised to be a
wife and you're like more of a
traditional woman you very well might be
but the way that you present yourself to
the world
and so it's like how if a guy was to
approach you yeah is he gonna approach
you like a wife or is he gonna approach
you like like a side well yeah obviously
I have guys approaching me every single
type of way but once once people know
what I'm on and know how I am then
they'll approach me the way like I want
to have it but we we start with looks
right so you're walking down the street
this is the way I choose to look
obviously I'm gonna attract the
different like a different reaction than
I originally won right but I but I ask
I'm just wondering why like why why live
on hard mode I don't really live on hard
mode this is just the way I choose
no I mean because you're beautiful so
I'm sure you I'm sure you get approached
regardless
by anyone at right now like but I just I
just wonder like why if you were raised
to be like traditional it's like I get
what you mean because even when I
started wearing the crop tops when I
started getting the tattoos trust me my
parents did not speak to me when I
started getting the tattoos they didn't
like they're all asking me why are you
just in this way if you were raised in a
very Christian household but it's just
the way I choose to present is your
reaction against I don't really think
it's a reaction against it's just my
personal style because I wear a crop top
but then I'll wear like something long
on my legs it's not like I'm showing my
whole body or I'm acting provocative or
I'm acting in a certain way with men
like maybe I'm that one example that
maybe you can present yourself in one
way and be completely the other because
as you say we speak about the huge
majority but it's not every single
person that's going to be like that I
don't remember if you said earlier do
you want to be married in the next
couple years married in the next couple
years so wouldn't it make sense to
present yourself like a wife yeah of
course okay so like yeah so can we take
out the notes ring I'll be so happy
she got two on her tongue one in her
belly you have a tongue ring too she's
got two
that determines the type of person I am
because if any of you took just 10
minutes out of your day to sit down no
you're very sweet I've spoken to you all
for sure yeah but it's it's more of the
way I present myself I agree I'm not
saying anything against like the way I
look the way I present myself I
completely agree the tattoos the
piercings the crop top it does say
something yeah I'm just saying it just
doesn't no I'm the reason I'm saying
this is because I want you to win yeah
like I want you to win in life yeah and
and it's like you know as as nice as it
is for for people to say oh where would
you want do like do what you want it's
like it's not going to help you get the
outcomes you seem to want
um it could to be honest I've come
across a lot of different people in my
life I've present myself in this way but
I get a lot of different reactions like
it's all about how you are as a person
like this is all about appearances
that's wrong because men judge you on
the way you look yeah men judge yourself
but then when they actually take that
extra stuff but they're not going to
take the extra step to see how you are
because they already put you in a box
and and what they're gonna think is hey
if I if I make her my wife if I if she's
my girlfriend she's gonna dress like oh
yeah like this and this is gonna
represent I'm not saying anything
against it like I agree men will think
that if I just certain way but that's
just not the way I am personally but
like surely if a guy came to you and
said like like first glance and didn't
give you the time of day just because of
your tattoos and the crop top and the
nose ring and whatever
you're you're emotionally intelligent
enough to the clock onto that and be
like okay well you're not the type of
guy there oh yeah that you would want
anything
I actually used to put this on my skin
I'm not that type of like cool maybe you
can think all sorts of crazy things
trust me I get all sorts of crazy
reactions of the type of tattoos I've
have with the types of dress like the um
the way I dress do you do you judge men
based on how they dress like if a guy is
dressed like a homeless of course as
so I'm saying like you started shaming
men for judging her okay well that's no
no no not you
and you were saying that oh well that's
not the type of man I would want anyways
but how do you know that because if you
saw a guy that was homeless that looked
homeless even even though he wasn't you
might disqualify him based on everyone
disqualifies everyone based on looks not
not shaming men as such but I'm just
saying like for her like I I'd hope that
she was emotionally intelligent enough
to be like okay well if you're gonna put
me in that box I have the equal right to
then say Okay then if you're gonna put
me in a box like that I can equally put
you in a box and move on with my life is
you're taking a defensive stance and I
think it's more about kind of being
conscious and aware of of things I think
I think the difference is is is like is
unnecessary you don't have to defend
yourself spiritually I think you just
have to be more conscious that like
those high level guys will notice the
tattoos but I don't care personally but
some guys will yeah you've got to just
accept that like I would say maybe if I
wanted to date like Bill Gates son or
like you know some Aristocrat from
France maybe he won't be into that yeah
and unfortunately because beautiful
he'll probably lie to you thank you I
just lost my Chain of Thought yeah
for like
I don't really judge people really like
I know people would 100 think things of
me just because just purely Based On My
Tattoos just on that fact alone but I
never let that really play into my mind
like I have a very realistic mindset
well I would just say if you if you do
want to be married or you do want a
long-term relationship then I would
dress like someone that wants to be in
one yeah but I'm married right now I
don't need anyone to like guide the way
I dress right now but obviously if I'm
married if I have a man no no I'm not
gonna be you said you wanted to get
married in the next couple years a
couple years yeah a few years more
likely a few years than a couple okay
okay maybe you need to add into that one
percent though like if you want to get
married to somebody from that one
percent no it's not no I'm sorry no it's
just
um no men across the board judge women
with tattoos
you know if we're gonna say a balance a
bit like there's exceptions but we're
going to talk about across the board the
menu like I'm from a pretty well-off
community and like most of my brothers
make six figures
um most people in our circles make six
figures and I can tell you that they
they absolutely judge you if you have
tattoos they absolutely judge you if you
have piercings and I didn't always like
this when I was younger I was like Mom
you're so judgmental why like I was so
mad that she wouldn't let me like do
this stuff and then the older I get the
more I see that she's right and I just
you know I really you know if if I can
encourage you in a different direction
that's probably what I'm gonna do it's
not to be on an end all though not at
all I think I think you could actually
end up making it something that works
for you you can a classy woman with
tattoo does stuff some Intrigue that
could be interesting so I'm not we're
not giving you like some kind of final
judgment yeah it's not a death sentence
at all yeah just just get a couple of
sundressers
they're great tattoos they love it
they're beautiful yeah thank you I
personally don't have a thing against
too but I'm not gonna lie if I saw
someone with tattoos it doesn't scream
take me out to dinner talk to me every
night treat me like wifey It kind of
screams like you've probably had two or
three toxic relationships like you know
yeah I get where you're that's my first
impression it's not you're on the
journey yeah yeah
but for real girls I would say
look at I do agree with feminists on one
thing in that you you go you women have
a lot against you now more than ever and
that you have the worst role models ever
like when I look at modern women there's
very few role models and I always get
the impression when I speak to
when I see the women others look look up
to other women look up to I just like
you're looking after people who don't
have what you want you're looking up to
women who are coping with their bad
decisions 34 year olds 32 year olds who
are still in the club who are trying to
sell you on this whole culture and
accept yourself and spirituality and
they're not they're missing out the
little bit where it says I messed up I
missed the boat I had all these
opportunities at Uni I had all these
opportunities I messed up and I'm still
in this club with 21 year olds trying to
pretend that I've got it all I guarantee
you these women if they found a decent
guy they would fight you too to know for
that guy so just just remember that not
everyone wants the best view and that's
what there's all all women not every
woman wants the best for you either
misery loves company agreed yeah they
will lie to your face straight straight
up like devil doesn't break into empty
houses does it and you're young you're
young you know they're gonna lie to you
take your time it's chill it doesn't
matter you know accept yourself you know
you got you got time trust me after uni
the amount of high quality guys you meet
on the dating scene will reach you
significantly in uni you're in a pool of
just young people who are quite focused
and going towards somewhere when you
come out you on Tinder right and Tinder
anyone could be on tender anyone could
be on hinge people are trying to mess
around people broke it's long and and
the more time kind of passes the less
high quality men there are because men
figure out and just pick one and bounce
the guys you see every day are the guys
that are running through girls in it
does
and then let's go back to the market
thing that Troy said the longer a house
sits on the market the more likely that
house is to drop in price yeah it
decreases in value right but I hate the
whole you just mentioned like Tinder and
all this stuff like when you guys like
and you dropped the word market as well
I don't like the whole idea that women
are
the whole thing is a market it's not
just women it's just everybody 100
so me personally like maybe call me
delusional call me naive but I just hate
the whole the whole hookup culture idea
that is so normalized today that don't
sit right on my conscience what who's
fault whose fault is hookup culture it's
the women's fault I think it's I think
it's the problem on both sides I don't
think what percent what percent of men
can partake in hookup culture what
percent of men get laid
I don't know the statistics or the facts
but I don't think it's a certain sex to
blame I think it's a problem I'm shared
on both sides we don't help each other
as women and I don't think men help
themselves either women want to sleep
with roughly 20 of men 20 of men and
some people would argue it's fewer but
we're going to say 20 of men are
sleeping with all the women
where 80 of women are sleeping with 20
of men so whose fault is hookup culture
is it more women doing it or more men
doing it I think you have the advantage
in this s like situation because
obviously you know the statistics like
I'm not sat behind a company I don't
know the statistics like but I just from
my personal opinion and what I see is
that I wouldn't blame it on a certain
sex and I'll hold my hands up and say
that yeah but it's not the five foot two
nerdy guys who are causing hookup
culture research you know what I mean I
think the point the point Pearl's making
is that you've got women who you know by
and large can can get access to sex
pretty easily for the most part not not
exclusive for the most part and then
you've got a certain a much smaller
sector of guys who are getting access to
that same sexually do you agree with the
saying women can and women sleep with
who they want and Men sleep with who
they can yeah but that but see that
that's something you agree with
personally yeah 99 of yeah
but so that supports what I'm saying so
women are The Gatekeepers yeah because
women are in control of who who gets sex
so if there's a hookup culture women
it's women who are in control of hookup
culture if all women said tomorrow we
all said all right guys we're closing up
shop until we get around our face
everyone would be married I would buy
Zale stock immediately no but that's
everyone the thing that's everyone and
we're not talking about everyone we're
talking the majority yeah but that is
that small percentage of people that
aren't like that we cannot speak for
everyone but we're talking in
generalities though okay but I'll Stand
to it for my personal opinion but that's
all I'm gonna say on that topic like I
don't think that will waver for me
personally
say that again what what wave a few like
I I don't I'm not happy with putting
that on one specific sex like I think
we're both part to blame for hookup
culture but you don't think if eight out
of ten women are participating it and
one out of every 10 or maybe two out of
every 10 men are participating it you
don't think it's more on the women
because more women are doing it I didn't
I don't like I don't live by like
statistics and facts like I just I like
to search
[Laughter]
that's going to be a great clip
is Drake is Drake you want a Scottish
I've been trying to say this the whole
show
it was more responsible for hookup
culture the the Thousand women that have
slept with Drake or Drake
laugh
men have the same thing right we all
want someone who doesn't have who hasn't
slept around but at the same time we've
also slept around a fair bit so I guess
I guess there's room on both sides You
could argue either Point that's what I'm
saying yeah yeah but I think Drake is
waiting for a virgin no nobody knows I
think his way I think I think most I
think most men I expect that the girl
has I mean I don't know any guy that's
genuinely no no there's one that came on
my show yeah that was genuinely waiting
for a virgin but that's like one out of
what the hundreds of men I've met all
year yeah
multiple girls come on the show and ask
for like we do the delusion calculator
20 30 of men
I mean even even just physical
characteristics if you think of a guy
you're attracted to I think Justin
you're like six three
like two percent like two percent of men
of six three and then on top of that
being good looking and then on top of
that having a good job and then on top
of that being intelligent so I go and
dance with a lot of girls in South and
all these kind of scenes and they're
good looking they get all this attention
and they think I should be chasing them
you work in a bar Sarah
yep like we're not we're not the same
but a lot of them don't understand that
so just understand the Rarity like high
quality good things are not are not
frequent I know on Instagram it looks
like you have access to the hottest guys
and you get all these DMs like you think
yeah you know I can replace them to the
left to the left that kind of idea real
solid guys I have like four friends but
actually that rate is people like this
is a decent guy I have a lot of friends
who will sleep with anyone and lie and
do anything that the woman asks just to
get some ass and I know the difference
high quality men are rare
I agree
so I think your your next what questions
do you have for men
I should have been here thinking about
that um
um because you've asked that most of
questions
um
Alex they're calling you a simp again ah
fair enough so be it
um I changed my answer every man is a
high value man
we all did love the best
um what is a high value like what would
a high value man look for in a high
value woman unless I was already
answered oh you did ask that question we
didn't answer it did we
no I don't think I asked that question
oh okay good yeah
oh yeah
I didn't ask them both for the women not
for the menu okay that was a good
question me personally I like
um women who are focused on their goals
who are driven on something even if
that's being a mother I like women who
have like a purpose
um one of the most beautiful women I
ever messed up with was a French girl
she was doing cyber security very solid
um she was she was single for a period
after graduating and then she got with
the guy she was with the uni and now
she's got a daughter and she's a senior
cyber security consultant a leading
engineering firm I've I've stopped big
time I should have I should have been
hustling for that but I was like 19 to
21. so yeah women who are focused who
kind of are focused on their job women
who are
um supportive and who understand how to
like compliment a man I don't like
combative women
um I can deal with one but I'd rather
not
um and I'll say
women who are selfless like any of this
talk about like you know what I deserve
or I what I'm owed what the world owes
you extremely honest I spoke to a god
hinge right and she was telling me how
all these Nigerian men in Manchester
wanted to wife her up and how like she
doesn't respect men unless they pay for
them pay for her food and stuff like
that that's a basic thing how can I
respect you if you don't even act like a
man this and that
um and I ignored everything she said and
asked her out because you know it was
just going to be some fun and she she
said oh you said link up and that means
that's disrespectful and he blocked me
this is like
this is this is the kind of
combativeness that kind of nature where
she felt need to tell me how to speak
yeah on top of those ridiculous demands
I think that is a bit much like but it's
a lot of women though yeah yeah I agree
with the fact that a man should pay for
dinner though yeah of course but I think
the exchange is a man takes that role
and then she takes a feminine role yeah
yeah that's the real exchange so do you
know like don't ask for equality if I'm
gonna pay for everything
put a woman in her feminine energy
period but but why is it why is it why
is it coming on the yeah to to put her
in it why shouldn't she be in it I think
as a man if you're not doing something
in the relationship that she needs or
she
is she she wants from you she's gonna
act in her masculine anymore I actually
kind of agree with this she's gonna
actually acting out yeah a little bit
because he's doing it it's his job to
take the role in the lead and that's
really why I was disagreeing with you so
hard on that being emotional nonsense
because if he comes home he's if you
translate what he's saying or got
problems in this and this he's saying I
can't take care of this I can't handle
it you should be scared because I am not
enough to handle the problems he should
come home and say I had a problem today
I absolutely took care of it you have
nothing to worry about yeah sleep like a
baby tonight I got this whole situation
I think when a man does that a woman has
no problem getting inside of a man a
really strong man's frame a masculine
man absolutely I just have no problem
see I just find that girls that say that
it's just like they're just not feminine
like the most feminine white girls like
they say what like when they say when
they say um I need a man to like put me
in my feminine energy oh
I think this I think there's two sides
to this I think on the one hand I think
you're right I agree with Justin I think
I think yeah a strong man is gonna put
you into your feminine and that's that's
absolutely correct however I also think
part of the problem is as I said women
are not approaching it from the point of
I should be in my femininity anywhere
also women in the western now again if
you go to South America or you go to
places in Eastern Europe and stuff like
that that aren't England and they aren't
America you get women who are much more
naturally in their film they don't they
don't need to be told oh you know I'm
going to act up unless I'm putting my
feminine they're just going to do it
naturally so I think it's kind of a
little bit of both
I think when I think of like the most
feminine women I know like like when I
think of like the archetype of like the
what I would like hope to be one day
right
there's just no man that they could talk
to that would make them masculine
because they're just so so feminine I
think what you said about like culture
and stuff like I'm I'm part Jamaican so
like Jamaican women they are very very
tough like you don't cross a Jamaican
woman you know what I mean so maybe
that's like integrated in my system
trauma in Jamaican communities we've got
to learn from that and that that is
passed on through I think culture does
make a big difference no but it is true
and with Jamaicans as well like I feel
like a lot of the time especially if
it's like single you have to be that
strong woman like I'm Jamaican you have
to be that strong woman
down yeah so a lot of the older
Generations they might have been
actually single and it's like they were
like that strong for like all their kids
like my grandma she had to be the single
woman I would call it trauma because
I've seen this cycle of single mothers
imparting all their horrible experiences
onto their kids and all this kind of
bullying and a lot of guys peaking at
high school and then using that to pray
on like 16 17 18 year old girls
basically bullying them with their
experience getting these girls pregnant
so I would say that's quite significant
I wouldn't say that's like normal mental
trauma like no you are actually
traumatized no you don't have to call it
traumatized because it's like you move
like you move on like I don't think it's
something that is like what is trauma
like trauma is not a event it's how you
take that I don't think trauma is real
because it's really and truly how you um
that's what you take from that
experience perceive it do you know I
mean it's not like oh I'm traumatized
because this happened you're traumatized
because you don't want to get over it or
you don't want to like better yourself
to like get over it there's levels
obviously yeah cool yeah could you
finish of course it's Devils yeah what
do you look for in a high value woman I
wasn't he was talking on it I'm finished
okay your turn
foreign
I don't know if I absolutely want what
they would call might call a high value
woman what what I think is very
important to me is no promiscuity yeah
or very you know
um how you Market yourself online in
2023 is very important
the role that you allow the man to take
by empowering him to be the hero no man
doesn't want to be a hero to his family
that's what makes love such a beautiful
thing no man wants a woman he can't save
from a castle under dragon not to say
that the woman is broken but he wants to
take the role of being appreciated for
taking care and putting everything on
the line for his family
very very important to me and any other
man and I have no problem saying that
in addition one thing we've we've not
really touched a lot is beauty men truly
care about beauty and keeping yourself
together you know and being clean and
and and soft in the way of a feminine
woman and really keeping up with that
especially as you start to get older I
think it's really important that you pay
attention to that because that's men
judge other men based off their girl and
it's very important to have a woman
that's not only beautiful and feminine
but it's also
willing to serve like in the feminine
role because it makes a man look good so
like let's say if you're at people come
over to your house or something like
that you you would ask his friends can I
get you guys anything like trying to be
trying to be like helping the group
because you respect the fact that they
might be talking about business not to
say that a woman can't do business I'm
just talking about a woman really being
in the feminine energy and even to a
degree submissive and I'm not sorry to
say it because really and truly no man
wants to date a person or be with a
person that he has to fight with to be
man of the house no of course no agreed
I agreed and you know what I think for
us females like that's so nice when you
can feel like you know you feel safe let
me defend you guys real quick this is
what's so hard for you guys there's so
much at risk for you to let go yeah
there's so much at risk and I feel like
in this Western World especially yeah
and you hold on to it because you don't
know if this son of a is actually
going to be able to do it yeah and
you're like so it's a defense
mechanism yeah you're trying to defend
yourself and Men ain't and I'm
gonna go on my journey because I'm going
to hold out and you know what sucks
about it a lot of times the girl's right
yeah
but it premises that with the title of
the show right
what really truly sucks for women and
where I truly feel bad for you where I
think your life is really really hard
you find the guy that can do it
and then he exercises options yeah but
what I would look for instead of that is
does he make you feel loved do you feel
safe will he sit down and have a heart
to heart did you you'll know if he
actually loved you or not yeah when you
get upset and you cry if he stops
everything he's doing cancels out and
he's with you truly and he can look you
in the eye and you know he's there for
you you know he's going to take care of
it and you feel safe around him safe
enough to let go you found the right guy
yeah anything short of that you're at a
major risk because you're risking it all
and I understand why a woman would want
to hang on to a little bit of her
Freedom if he didn't think he could
handle it and that's why I would never
tell a man to cry to a woman because
you're telling her I can't handle it
which is going to make her look
elsewhere to find somebody who can
and that's just how it's always been and
that's how it is
what about you
um I think uh beauty is really important
like like you said I think I think that
is a key thing without wanting to sound
shallow but it's not shallow it's just
that that is how we're built I think so
I think that is super key I think
sweetness and femininity are
the the the ultimate things that stick
out to me really like you said you don't
want to be in a situation with somebody
where it's going to be competitive right
I mean I was in a I was in a situation
that was very brief because I didn't
allow it to continue with with a woman
who was incredibly competitive
um and and really tried to sort of
I don't know man I mean she was just off
on a different thing and it was like I
can't I can't live with this and I don't
want to live with this I don't want to
live in this situation this isn't what
how is this pleasurable right you know I
want to be with somebody who is who is
sweet who's feminine who's nurturing and
who you can and who who also makes an
effort to understand the male position
in all of this as well because I think a
lot of women don't or they and they
don't try to and I think it's important
for her to understand the male side of
things and somebody as well where you're
looking for that ride or die really
ultimately aren't you you know somebody
who you could be honest with and say
look this is me this is how this is
going to go
there may be times when you know I'm
gonna go and do something over here but
it I love you you are my queen you are
the old you know you are the the top of
the pile for me but you've got to accept
the realities of my nature and I think
uh a woman who can have that
conversation and not get you know overly
emotional and understand from the
masculine point of view why that
conversation has to happen I think that
is the the ultimate thing for me really
I agreed I think it's just so different
difficult for us females like going back
to what you said when we we want to be
in our like we want a guy to completely
just take care of us and protect us and
be that hero you know every girl we've
been told all these fairy tales all
these stories when we're growing up
we're fed it from when we were kids
oh my God we got through to them
it's the guy saving the female all the
time so I think that's when it hurts so
much when you finally say oh my God okay
I can let go I'm finally in my feminine
energy I don't have to protect myself
anymore I can finally go and that's why
it hurts so much when you see the guy
that you think you can do that with and
then they go out and
exercise the options like you said
that's why it hurts so much and that's
when it goes back to the original
questions to where you stay or do you go
also I tell you this is that for you sex
in a lot of ways equals love
for a minute does not yeah you know and
I think that's what's painful you like
how could he possibly do that when I
don't want to do that at all truly so
most women that are truly in love with a
man don't want us they don't know
another man exists and I think you said
that earlier and it's absolutely true so
for you you can't comprehend just like
we can't comprehend your your position
how could he possibly
love me the way I love him and still do
that and and you're completely valid in
that feeling it's just trying to get
through to anyone like men don't feel
that way they don't explicitly say
because that's I think without without a
shadow of a doubt and that's why and
that's why I made the point earlier how
far men will go down the totem pole to
do it it haunts men in a lot of ways I'm
telling you I think that is the question
that I would ask when you say to me what
question do you want to ask men that is
the question when that happens
is it is it love or is it just complete
just blind I don't care about that girl
I don't care about that I promise you he
does not care about her okay
even more if he's like not say being
open in it like way worse he's like
sneaking out the house and come back in
he's got his family he knows how you act
like that must be even worse your
grandfather I think was a good example
because he did that he had he had that
kind of other side of his life but he
treated his main woman with so much
respect that he didn't shame her by
making it open yep respect and I respect
her for that because I think at some
point another thing I didn't mention
it's about compromise I like women who
are naturally feminine who naturally
understand like listen I'm slightly less
successful than Justin right slightly
right I've got one or two million less
right so not every man's gonna be a
superhero and everyone's gonna have
their flaws and being able willing to
kind of meet them halfway and talk about
things is is such a rare trait and the
prettier women get the less likely they
want to do that the more they want to
see a man bend over and start in the DMS
and do all these things because they
think I can do it and they all get
played because the guys that will do
that are doing it because they're horny
that's it yeah
though is there a conscience after in
what way after that happens after they
do that like is there a conscience
thinking yeah yeah if they're running
around lying to people yes absolutely
absolutely and that's why it's so
important you to me truly a high value
man will live in truth yeah and this
undermines the whole toxic masculinity
exercise because because what you always
talk about is that he's actually just
being honest and authentic this is this
is my nature honesty this is how I am
and what's toxic how can you how can
anyone say that's toxic right I'll put
it to you like this if I if I love
myself
I have to believe that so many but
somebody would love me just the way I am
in full truth yeah and and the fact of
the matter is most the time when a man
gets caught he has been caught in
deception
so not only is he a liar he's a coward
and how can you respect a coward yeah
yeah that is truth that's very true that
is true I agree okay
raise it hands who thinks that they
could accept cheating if the guy was
open about it definitely what do you
mean it's not just opening not not give
him a hard time about it not bring it up
just yeah this is what he does I don't
think any woman's actually capable of
that because I think there'll be spurts
of outbursts and pain you have you have
the library right don't be spurts about
birds and pains and that is one of the
most important parts for a man if that
happens you have a job to stop what the
you're doing and be there and sit
in that pain with her and help make it
better
I'm not talking about a man that doesn't
actually love you like this man will
actually love you and that's been the
hardest thing for for people to
understand especially and that's one of
the things I hated the most when I was
going through the pain of like breaking
up with girls I had feelings for is
I was in love with these girls I would
have sat down with them and and been
there I wouldn't have cried but I'd have
held them
you understand what I'm saying it's like
you don't have to be a dick to a woman
just because you're doing that it's this
is really about getting down to the
brass tacks of how we're actually wired
so you don't even want to do it it's
just oh like I said I paid it I'd pay
for it to go away and so it's so
interesting because you said
um like you you may have married those
girls absolutely yeah and the thing is
they may have gotten what they wanted if
they could have accepted that and and
you know what I think about that truly
all the the women that are like okay
I can see the world for how it is
this sucks it's gonna hurt but I believe
him he loves me he makes me feel this
way jokes on all the other women because
they're getting the man and guess
what those men if given the
opportunity in a heartbeat not only will
do it but lie about it
and to me I look at those two scenarios
who's really winning yeah who's really
winning one of them's getting truth and
real love and probably a much better
life the other one's getting lied to and
getting a scrub and a coward yeah and
that's just that's just how it is so
who's a joke on really it and when when
you read all these books and you hear
all this stuff and you hear these women
kind of being super masculine with the
attitude around it they've probably
never met a man who could sit down with
them and be emotionally intelligent
enough to love them through it and
explain it in an articulate enough way
with enough conviction not hiding from
it that they could ever be able to
accept it
one misconception a lot of modern women
have is that your value is in your
ability to sexually please a man so I
think older women know that
it's about your ability to take care of
the homes your feminine energy so they
think a lot of people women feel if you
cheats on me then it means I'm nothing
to him and I have no values throw me
away no no I slept with you for the
first time years ago we've already read
that book now your value is that you're
the wife like you're the pillar of this
house you make the food you make this a
home you're supportive you're you're the
love of my life in some ways you're my
peace yeah you need you need to Pivot to
that because all this like new feminist
ideology low-key sells you the idea that
like it's about the sex sex last five
minutes This Woman's gonna give up a
multi-millionaire happy life all those
connections that for five because he
bust a nut in someone else and she's
gonna give up all that because she
thinks that's that's all that matters
with us that's that's the definition of
relationship and it's not you up
old school Queens will tell you that you
think you think a queen would would
divorce the king if that's even possible
because he has a concubine nah because
you're still the Queen that's
why yeah yeah
it's true well but I feel like we've
been fed for so long that it's like if
you do that then you have no value then
you're like
when my shoes they always paint it like
the men are the like the worst that is
the worst thing they could possibly do
when it's like well we're not perfect
either yeah and so it's like we expect
all this stuff from men we expect them
to provide for us we expect them to be
masculine to lead be good looking tall
um successful and it's like if he he
checks every single box and he cheats oh
you should throw a good thing away you
should throw away your whole family and
never be it's not like you're gonna
replace him yeah so you my response to
that is you're gonna leave me for a man
that you love less that'll cheat on you
anyway
hmm
because even you talk to like married
couples and they've been together for
long like I realize they always start
with oh there's ups and downs
and downs is like talking about them
situations where it's like yeah you
cheated I'm not happy about it but it's
that we move on because I love him I
don't believe in divorce look it's a
complete double standard because if a
woman cheats on a man he will leave her
in a second yeah because they know it's
emotional with women but it's like it's
like the trade-off thing right he's
going to go through all this hell and go
through all the stress and make sure
your world is a Carpet Ride
and there's just one thing inside of him
that is in every side of every man but
you'll notice that he will not give
material assets to those other women
yeah but do you know it's funny I feel
like women really and truly like when
you're actually in the situation that
you're more upset with men that cheat
that that are not playing their role
like everybody's cheating I'm not paying
you can actually effort that's the
deceitage
you're not gonna tell me you don't do
nothing my life sucks
like if the man is a father he's a like
your husband he like listens to
everything you say and then he cheats of
course you're gonna feel a type of way
but it's something you're going to work
through because it's like this is my
husband we're building a life together
so would you say that men making more
money in a way gives them the right to
cheat not just money it's like the whole
world they emotionally need to
because a lot of people just throw money
out and they stop it at money no I mean
love the woman yeah I mean lover that's
why you can't just cool anyone a high
value man until you know them because
high value men comes with so many
qualities not just money oh he's a
millionaire but he she get it like
that's character
to me in my opinion